[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
back at e3 2019 a new IP from the
creators of Gears of War judgment and
Bulletstorm
was revealed in all the mystique it took
until 2020 to be playable in preview
form we were invited over to snowy
Poland and sat down without riders so
what the heck is it and how does it feel
well here's 25 things you should know
about outriders I'm going to start by
combining a few games to give you an
overall instant understanding outriders
has the potential to bring together the
gritty nature of Gears of War the
inventory management of something like
the division of Ghost Recon break point
and the character abilities of destiny
lofty claims I know on the surface
outriders is trying to push together as
many popular video game elements as it
can into one single entity before we
break down the story and characters
let's get our head around the core
mechanics in place
guns gear and grandeur the first part of
that trilogy are the weapons that's 90%
of what you do in this game
while the preview builds at least and if
you haven't guessed already outriders is
most certainly a shooter in a nutshell
the enemies set up behind cover and we
push forward to get through them as
quickly as possible
this means gunplay is paramount and
there's one thing that makes every
bullet feel fantastic dismemberment for
guns to feel really weighty and heavy
and have thoughts behind them the
greatest thing you can do is rip through
the opposition physically shotguns and
snipers are king here in terms of
weapons though in game there are also
assault rifles submachine guns semi-auto
rifles pistols and even revolvers Oh
unlike machine guns - variation is the
key to shooters and outriders has enough
to keep you satisfied
[Music]
part two of that Holy Trinity of
gameplay is the gear out riders also
want to be a pretty deep RPG the key
mechanic here is gear and weapons course
I'm going to say this a lot but if you
play destiny other division or Ghost
Recon wildlands even Assassin's Creed
has it these days
gear score is vital and it's always in
out riders split into two categories of
armor rating for defensive items and
firepower ratings for weaponry as we
progress through the game loot drops
give us that sweet sweet nectar to level
up our gear scoff I don't have a great
example now but completing a level for
that crusty coat to replace your
battered one may not sound or inspiring
but we all know chasing a gear Scott of
flex is the key reason we return to
these games daily on the side of
weaponry it becomes pretty simple higher
weapon score means our guns hit harder
with more stopping power eventually we
will hit the inevitable unkillable boss
which will force us to grind missions in
the hope of acquiring a weapon and a
tire set strong enough to progress
forward rinse and repeat
it's an addictive gameplay mechanic you
have to admit so what's the final part
of our gameplay loop it's our character
abilities our grandeur throwing down
bullets slowing bubbles or flaming
during pie romancing or anti-gravity
mayhem who we choose molds our
experience but before we look in depth
at their abilities is important to know
that we level up our characters by
playing the game each time this happened
our health increases our abilities grow
become buffed we become more potent in
our attacks and unlock new abilities
which once again keeps us coming back
for more and more and importantly it
also changes the way we approach the
game with new skills we're going to talk
about repetition very soon and that's
why I'm trying to point out already the
ways the game breaks up that repetition
anyway character classes let's go
[Music]
now traders will have four classes to
choose from on day one which as you'd
expect have different abilities we got
to see three of them with the last one
remaining a mystery until nearer the
release date first the Pyromancer this
class is a medium-range area of
effective specialists literally wielding
fire I tell no lies there's a thermal
bomb which turns any enemy hit into a
ticking time bomb walking around until
the moment they die and then they go
boom in addition there's a firewall
which tears across the battlefield which
helps move enemies out of position and
cover paramon cesare the middle ground
between the two other classes as they're
not as tanky as devastators and they're
not as rapid as tricksters but let's be
serious you choose this guy for the fire
they're like Angry charmander's the
Devastator is the second class is
essentially a tank of the group strong
tough durable all those types of words
they control gravity though turning the
ground beneath them into a weapon
specking them into a close combat
specialist that Wade's into damage their
powers even allow them to leap literally
into the fight cover themselves in rock
and send the enemies flying with
ridiculous ground-pound skills the third
class we've seen thus far is the
trickster focused more on speed and
efficiency designed for up-close combats
with probably the coolest ability I've
seen in a video game for a long time a
time bubble the trickster bend the laws
of space and slows down time bullets can
be seen floating pasts gradually it's
definitely a WoW moment this outrider
can use their abilities to both defend
and be more attacking and did I mention
they also have a teleportation to jump
around the battlefield moving to a
target deal some damage and get out of
there oh and the melee attack of the
trickster turns enemies to skeletons
if you like me and stories important
here's an ultra quick breakdown of law
after the earth is destroyed by war and
good old climate change too we are
forced to look elsewhere in the galaxy
as an outrider we are seen as elite
forces the pioneers who spearhead the
search for a new planet to call home
upon finding the planet of Enoch a storm
rips through everything this anomaly has
hyper evolved the planet creating a
world filled with deadly flora and fauna
our outriders didn't get through that
storm unharmed they were changed at a
molecular level the game picks up 30
years later as we exit cryosleep to
understand this new planet and the
strange anomaly that happened pretty
damn epic starting point now we've
scratched the surface let's jump a
little deeper outriders uses a skill
tree approach to help us build the
character we want this can be as general
or specific as you decide each class has
a general class trait but then a
plethora of options open up will you
first decide to increase your own health
or maybe your attack power and then
before you know it you're deciding to
amp up your armor penetration or
increase your resistance each decision
you make defined your play style finding
your strengths and weaknesses on top of
the skill trees will be modded weapons
we haven't seen much of this to show so
far so it's really between chats with
devs and other creators as we try and
piece this together at this point it
looks like it's something built for the
end game for the ultra dedicated to
strive towards it's quite difficult to
craft the game both for casual players
and hardcore players and maybe weapon
mods will be the definitive difference
between the two we shall sing on that
one but we know they exist at this point
by now I'm sure you've noticed the other
players in this gameplay footage once
again just like destiny and other games
in the looter shooter RPG genre
outriders is made for three players
Sascha gaming is what keeps us coming
back meeting up with our friends and
taking down a difficult boss together or
casually chatting whilst we grind
through some lower level runs outriders
classes itself as a drop-in dropout
experience upon further investigation it
has been confirmed that the game changes
difficulty to accommodate those
additional players and they also won't
punish you if two of your friends leave
in essence this should allow a low-level
player to work with a veteran without
one being out of place with their
firepower I'm still to see a game which
does this well probably Borland 3 was
the closest to achieving this but hey if
the game supports dropping drop out then
I'll be joining your game just before
you kill the main boss and taking that
precious loot okay I'm only kidding that
I can't take your loot loot is instanced
in outriders meaning you can't touch my
loot and I can't touch yours either
our drops are independent and are scaled
to our character level accordingly in
many games having your loot taken is a
key reason people just give up and move
on even when it's made into a mechanic
like the dark zone in the division loot
theft prevents a huge percentage of
gamers from continuing in that gaming
world so in out writers your loot is
your loot to finish this section on
co-op gameplay a really important thing
to note is about teens synergy using the
weapon mods and more importantly the
character abilities to build the
ultimate force class gear mods
playstyles skill tree direction each
affect the battlefield when going up
against out riders hardest foes this
will become essential in practice this
can throw up some really impressive
scenarios for example we saw a trickster
bubble being thrown down to slow down
bullets while the Devastator used
gravitational force to shatter enemies
it's honestly freaking awesome to see so
although we can play alone the best
moments happen in a team
let's talk about repetition think of
most of the multiplayer games you've
played most have an element of
repetition how many times have you
jumped out of the battle bus and
fortnight how many times have you raided
in destiny how many times have you
killed the same boss in a video game a
lot right
well once again repetition will play a
part in outriders replay missions was
available almost instantly in the
preview and it's been confirmed as
imperative to grinding your character to
the level you desire I think we've all
got to a point now where repetition in
video games is pretty fundamental but as
long as the core gameplay loop gives you
that lovely feeling of satisfaction in
sight this won't be an issue for you the
world of outriders has some open-world
elements but is most definitely not an
open-world game each area or zone is
connected but we cannot run through them
seamlessly instead smaller open areas
are at work here to quickly navigate we
can use fast travel points and a nice
addition here has us placing down flags
which then activate quick travel spots
ensuring our outriders explore the
intended area first before jumping
around instantly the story about riders
has was attempting to understand the
anomaly and how we survived out in the
world we quickly realize we aren't the
only ones with these strange abilities
tracking down other super beings becomes
a staple of the game resulting in sacred
boss fight encounters and yes you've
already guessed it they're good or
bullet sponges long drawn-out encounters
in which you must survive additional
minion Falls thrown into the closed off
area as well as continuously taking down
the bosses extensive health stacks
people did note that tactics were quite
important in these encounters other
little tidbits to note there is a
character creator although at the
preview event this was not very deep but
it has gender haircuts tall that hang on
can we um can we say gender anymore
anyway various phases hair styles and
facial scales were available too and
further customization will rely on your
gear system so we'll talk about that
near at the time emotes are also
confirmed and here's a nice one a
teabagging emote how very original or
another little thing there's a truck to
assist with travel
but we haven't seen it yet so we'll have
to wait for that one too oh and this is
a really important one outriders have
confirmed there will be no loot boxes in
the game they've described this as a
complete experience out of the box a
cosmetic items that do feature in the
game like emotes banners customization
that sort of thing are unlocked through
in-game accolades so play to unlock so
when does outriders hit the stores well
it's not summer 2020 anymore sadly
outriders has slipped back slightly to
holiday 2020 go and have a random guess
when you think it's coming out I'll go
November 3rd complete guess outriders
he's coming to the PS 5 as well as the
ps4 and the new Xbox as well as a
current Xbox and of course the good old
PC so that was our time with outriders
I'm hoping I didn't call it out Landers
during the entirety of this video if I
did I'm very sorry thank you very much
for your time it's hugely appreciated
I'm Adam from PlayStation granade a
quick thank you to Jaime who went to
Poland to get this footage I appreciate
your brother and I will see you all very
soon thanks for your time
[Music]